we've got over 50 people coming a lot of
friends and family coming over here and
we want to be ready for the election
[Applause]
oh my goodness
Chef wonderful here can't believe where
I am Los Angeles that's right and who's
this yes the celebrity chef Aaron made
from the Food Network of course let's
check out the timepieces right let's
check it out to the restaurant ready
here we go here we go
[Music]
what are we talking about here what is
that that looks like some strange
material it is bronze I love a Bronze
Watch in the kitchen rubber strap bronze
style bronze case yeah it's very
versatile in the kitchen hot pans hot
water ovens it starts to Patina looks
really nice this is the IWC Aqua timer
Charles Darwin Edition classic so what's
the theme with this darwinian thing you
know food evolves people evolve you know
and that's kind of what we're doing
today we got football on we're
tailgating yeah this is the evolution of
the tailgate before I can even start on
the food I have to try the wine now
little secret here we're going to be I
want Aaron to try my O'Leary Fine Wines
a Chardonnay to start which is a classic
when you're footballing you gotta have a
glass of white ready for this they say
Chardonnay is football right exactly
Aaron tell me what you think your first
notes the hints
I mean it's it's green apples right off
the nose
that is delicious
[Applause]
Chihuahua that's a
touchdowne oh Larry Fine Wines where I
can get these QVC any time of the day or
night and the shipping's included under
12 a bottle isn't that amazing for this
it's a first down all right now this
I've gone with a Meritage I've Blended
myself personally five different frames
firstly I did at the Village I like it
it's got a huge nose eh now let's go
that's nice
that is really good it's it's not too
fruity not too tannin it's really well
balanced I mean you did a great job with
that I appreciate it now let's get down
to the cooking
[Music]
we've got andouille sausage and
bratwurst you know you want to bring a
lot of different flavors to the party
hot dogs bratwurst kielbasa and Dewey
and then these are a prime rib night cut
in half wrapped up tight keep the juices
in we're eating good today Kevin
[Music]
Mr Wonderful here and there's no debate
about this small businesses in America
create over 60 percent of the jobs but
times are tough is there a solution yes
the government employee retention credit
program go to wondertrust.com today all
right everybody here we are very
important session of the kitchen about
to happen with Chef Aaron because we've
got over 50 people coming I thought I'd
drop in so a lot of friends and family
coming over here and we want to be ready
for the election because everybody's
going to be hungry everybody's going to
really be interested in what the chef's
putting together I'm just here assisting
and observing but that's why you always
find Chef wonderful in the best places
at the best times ready to monge okay
let's go through what you're planning
for the crew today we're gonna moche
yeah on some delicious morsels of food
I've got
we've got the bone-in prime rib
you get all the extra sort of juice from
the bone-in cut so we got the prime rib
I'm doing Burgers obviously you know I
love my meat dishes you know no matter
what happens after you've had a couple
of beers you gotta Chow Down on a burger
I totally get it Burger's only good
ballast for the rest of the game right
you like kind of they're the snack
snacks they're the Special Teams almost
right right okay so now we've got two
big proteins you got the slab of
brontosaurus over there you got Bergs
fantastic Broncos and birds what about
the accoutrements so you gotta start
light right you don't want to kill
everything before the action vaccion
really starts right we've got a
charcuterie board beautiful cheeses
Meats they go great with the O'Leary
Chardonnay we're gonna make a little
shrimp ceviche ah we're going to
Ecuadorian style roasted tomatoes
onions really get some flavor out of
there so you're snacking on Ceviche
you're eating some charcuterie oh Larry
wines one more time all right just a
little sip so then you know we're gonna
go brunchy too though right some people
maybe stayed out too late last night not
us a little crispy around the edges a
little crispy around the edges you want
to give them a little back to like rocks
and bagel yeah eggs benedict and then
we've got sweets football themed treats
oh my goodness
all colors on the cookie pot look
incredible that's a oh that's the little
footballs look at the little football oh
that is so cool that is so cool of
course I'll be chowing these down later
as well now let's talk about how you're
going to prepare this how does this work
are you going to have a buffet style
thing with this many people so we're
going to set up I've got all these big
boards yeah we've got all this beautiful
stuff we're making all these great
snacks and we're just gonna kind of put
them right there on the counter yeah and
let everybody I think you and me will be
standing here with glasses of wine kind
of just picking absolutely everybody
else will be over there on the couch
making themselves slovenly let's talk
about timing how do you play this out
you gotta have something ready when
everybody arrives right they come in in
waves right so people arrive you put the
charcuterie out yeah we got the meats
the cheeses the olives the jams we're
gonna make a little Ceviche that will
keep refreshing so it's nice and cold
and beautiful and then we'll slowly
start rolling out the snacks right have
some eggs benedict have some like some
Bagel have some cheeseburgers let's
maybe make some tacos okay how about a
hot dog at halftime there's been a lot
of turnover in rest during the pandemic
a lot of classic places went down
absolutely a lot of new guys showed up
what's going on out there you know right
now I think the food scene in L.A is
better than it's ever been there's some
amazing stuff I mean there's Cambodian
restaurants Thai restaurants lay ocean
restaurants Greek Italian even like
little micro restaurants celebrating
like the food of South Italy do they
have to have a direct consumer strategy
in terms of delivery or are they just
relying back on people's coming in and
sitting down I think that you know La is
so spread out I think that the
convenience factor of delivery is huge
it's forever right it's huge yeah I want
to take you to a restaurant it's 45
minutes away right it's a long drive
after someone very Fine Wines yeah
exactly is there any one theme of food
type that you find is really taken off
bigger than three years ago you you know
I think that we're seeing in La
especially right now the evolution of
the steakhouse you mean an upward move
an upward move new places I can't
remember the last time you had so many
new entries into such a classic genre
right fox hall Steakhouse in Culver City
is amazing Kent State La Cienega steak
48 on Wilshire all these new ones that
catch place is crazy I love it it's
amazing so the idea is that it's a Chop
House elevated Seafood also salads and I
think atmosphere too right gone are the
days of like the business dinner
Steakhouse right you can go have a great
time we're making a little camo bearing
meatball dip we talked about snacking
how important having accessible fingers
snacking Foods is going to be we're
gonna line this with meatballs roll it
all up bake it off and then you'll dip
it in the camel bear almost like a
meatball fondue
okay
[Music]
what's going on with the slack this is
the uh the primer we took it off the
bone
we gotta lay down nicely we made a
horseradish in a Bernice yeah this is
the presentation what's happening I've
got Ashley with the bones yeah you can
see those nice rib bones nothing more
Sunday afternoon and eating a big piece
of prime rib on the bone it's gonna take
some of that Orange Juice Stop The
Magicians
a little chef wonderful Horsey Sauce
yeah I put a little Chinese mustard in
here to get a little bit of extra heat
amazing now this is what I'm talking
about this is tailgating it's a big guy
from La Chef Aaron Meg baby it's a
wonderful pleasure cooking with you
today wow